AS WE ARE SET TO GO.
GLAD TO HAVE HIGH, AND SHOT OFF
THOMPSON, MAKE HIS Kelly: THAT'E
SIDE OF THE NET, AND THIS, I
BELIEVE, FRONT, THEY
SCORE!
DYLAN DUBÉ ON THE POWERPLAY, AND
IT'S AND SEE THIS
JACOB MARKSTROM MARKSTROM,
INCREDIBLE READ BY UP TO THE FA.
AND THIS ONE IS ALL TIED AS JACK
SMART PLAY, BY JANMARK, IN THE ,
THERE'SS THENN WE
WHICH WE KIND OF EXPECTED IT TO
BE. AN SIDE OF THE
NET, AND ALL OF A SUDDEN, WHAT
LOOKED TO BE TWO GOOD CLEARING
ATTEMPTS BY THE AMADIO, AS HE ST
EFFORT.
AND THAT TURNOVER, CERTAINLY
COST THE
ATTACK.
SWINGS THIS RIGHT, FLAMES BENCH.
AND AT THISPANE DOWN THE WING, S
THE PASS, STOPS, HANIFIN,
STOPPED BYE BY THE
FLAMES TO GET IT RIGHT BACK TO
NOAH HANIFIN HANIFIN, GAUDREAU
AGAIN, PASSING, LINDHOLM, IN
TO MATTHEW TKACHUK, AND
SC
SCORES.
>> NOT SURE IF THAT WAS TIPPED
MIGHT HAVE BEEN ROY WHAT,
THERE'SERIOD FACE OUT
OVER, LINDHOLM, STOPPED B B SHOG
POSITION, NOTOTHITECLOUD PRESSUY
.
AS
AS HE A AND I FINDS CARLSON,
BUT NOT A LOT OF C C